avec nous sophie Brochu président
directrice générale d’hydro-québec
bonsoir madame Brochu bonsoir
importante évidemment est-ce que c'est
une proposition qui est arrivée comme ça
un peu sans crier gare ou est-ce que
cette acquisition de great River hydro
faisait partie d'une stratégie
d'expansion bien réfléchie ben écoutez
ça fait partie d'une stratégie
d'expansion puis je vais répondre vous
permettrez à la question que vous posez
Hydro-Québec quand je suis arrivée en
poste on me posait la question ce qui
est au Québec va poursuivre l'examen
d'opportunité à l'international et
j'avais exprimé le fait que tout près de
nous dans le cours arrière il y avait
les Etats-Unis que je considérais pas de
l'international parce que c'est tout
près de chez nous et donc cette
transaction là elle est dans le couvre
arrière vous le disiez très bien avec
votre collègue d'ailleurs vous avez un
topo parfait je vous donne une note de
c'est une transaction qui fait plein de
sens et au Québec va étudier au moins
une trentaine de transactions
potentielles au cours des derniers mois
nous sommes très très disciplinés
évoluant nous assurer que nous allions
faire une transaction qui allait être
profitable financièrement et
intelligente au plan industriel on n'est
pas un fond de passion on achète pas des
actifs pour les spinner après on est là
pour les garder donc ça c'est arrivé sur
le marché des appels d'offres c'est un
processus concurrentiel on est très
heureux d'être là où on est aujourd'hui
puis ce sera extraordinaire pour hydro
et pour le Québec pour les décennies
futures bon le montant que vous avez
payé quand même madame Brochu deux
milliards de dollars là c'est le double
que ce qui avait déboursé le fond un
clite energy Partners en 2017 est-ce que
c'est quand même une bonne affaire ce
que vous réalisez aujourd'hui oui
absolument faut savoir que en 2017 puis
2022 il y a une évolution considérable
du marché de l'énergie en général sur le
marché du nord-est américain il faut
savoir que maintenant sur le marché du
nord-est américain on peut vendre je
dois vous simplifier ça trois produits
on peut vendre de l'énergie on peut
vendre de la capacité et on peut vendre
ce qu'on appelle des Rex ou des
attributs environnementaux et c'est
l'ensemble de ces produits là qui
aujourd'hui sont attrayants d'autant que
quand on regarde devant nous le prix qui
sera payé pour les énergies
renouvelables est appelée à s'accroître
et ça c'est une conviction d'une thèse
d'Hydro-Québec qui s'appuie sur la
volonté des des populations là-bas des
dirigeants et des autorités
réglementaires donc ce qu'on voit devant
nous est très porteur très prometteur et
puis je peux vous dire que dès la
première journée ou cette transaction va
être va être derrière nous elle va déjà
être profitable pour vivre au Québec bon
vous devez quand même la financer et là
on a des clients l'Hydro-Québec qui nous
écoutent rassurez-vous là il y aura pas
d'impact sur les tarifs absolument c'est
vraiment deux marchés complètement
différents la clientèle c'est un c'est
un modèle d'affaires sur le nord-est
américain qui est en complément de ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on prend notre énergie on
l'exporte sur des lignes existantes
c'est qu'on prend notre énergie et on va
construire de nouvelles lignes pour
atteindre de nouveaux marchés en faire
davantage soit ici on achète des actifs
qui sont déjà là déjà construits déjà
raccordés avec un marché porteur donc ça
c'est inscrit en complément d'une série
d'outils pour nous permettre une
présence accrue et signification dans un
marché qui nous plaît mais des actifs en
nouvel Angleterre madame Bochu qui
auront peut-être besoin d'amour on parle
de central qui ont été construites bon
il y a 30 parfois 50 ans on aura des
besoins d'investissement et on a évoqué
aussi un potentiel pour le terrain qui
est en quelque sorte assorti le dans
cette transaction il y aura donc des
investissements à venir oui et puis
d'ailleurs ça a été prise en compte les
investissements maintenant sont été
prises en compte dans le prix que nous
avons payé faut savoir que des barrages
bien construits et bien entretenues ça
peut vivre très très longtemps et c'est
un des attraits de ce type
d'investissement là il se trouve que on
a envoyé nos équipes faire une
vérification des légendes de chacun de
ses actifs là ils sont revenus avec un
regard très positif sur ce qui avait été
fait Adam on a une bonne idée de ce qui
doit être fait à courir à moyen terme on
est très confortable avec ça puis on va
assurer la pérennité de tout ça donc une
première activité ça c'est
vous l'évoquez bien ce sont des terrains
importants et quand on pense par exemple
energy solaire quand on pense couper des
batteries avec tout ce qui s'en vient on
va avoir un terrain de jeu là qui va
être profitable pour le déploiement
industriel puis l'attractivité
financière pour les clients qu'on va
servir je vous entends un petit peu plus
tôt aujourd'hui madame Brochu vous ne
fermiez pas la porte à d'autres
acquisitions est-ce que ce serait
toujours dans le nord-est des États-Unis
où vous vous considérez de nouveau
plusieurs marchés internationaux non non
absolument pas jouer très clair là on
n'est pas du tout d'abord c'est de
l'ouvrage de faire des acquisitions puis
faire une acquisition c'est somme toute
assez simple après faut que tu l'opères
et quand tu as besoin d'aller visiter
tes équipes discuter avec les dirigeants
travailler avec tes clients quand il
faut que tu prennes l'avion et que tu
partes pendant une semaine c'est une
chose là on prend notre tour au bout de
trois heures on est là puis il y a tant
à faire tout près de chez nous puis on a
vraiment là une capacité de synergies
qu'on n'aurait jamais à l'international
fait que c'est pas tout d'amis ton
expertise il faut être capable de créer
une synergie qui va faire du sens au
final puis là c'est beau on va être
capable de contribuer puis vous savez
quoi on va beaucoup apprendre des gens
qui opère ses barrages-là dans leur
réalité je suis convaincu qu'on va avoir
un échange qui va être profitable pour
tout cela dedans bon alors des
investissements on le sent là dans cette
région qui est notre cours arrière comme
vous le dites si bien mais des
intentions à tout le monde si on écoute
le Premier ministre de nouveau barrage
au Québec c'était en quelque sorte dans
votre plan stratégique également vous en
êtes où dans cette réflexion
mais en fait notre pain stratégique vous
le savez il est en plusieurs blocs le
premier c'est l'efficacité énergétique à
court terme il faut pousser ça il y a
beaucoup de potentiel là-dedans qui vont
nous éviter ou qui vont reporter des
ouvrages de production mais tenir
investir en maintenant ce qu'on va le
faire aux États-Unis quand on fait de la
maintenance on améliore l'efficacité des
ouvrages existants beaucoup d'éoliens et
puis en parallèle de tout ça on fait une
mise à jour présentement de nos de nos
évaluations puis des potentiels
hydroélectriques du Québec alors les
rivières quelle rivières combien de
capacités combien d'énergie quels sont
les impacts environnementaux qu'ils
seraient les considérations sociales les
discussions avoir avec les communautés
autochtones puis au final de tout ça
quels sont les coûts qui sont attachés
alors c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire et puis on verra au final de tout
ça en fonction de l'évolution de la
demande également au Québec
si quel est le meilleur ouvrage de
déclencher au moment où ça sera requis
vous avez vous les avez mentionné cet
élément là qui nous préoccupe en
particulier le coût en dernier ça coûte
cher à construire ces grands ouvrages là
même si la demande est au rendez-vous
est-ce qu'il est au Québec pourrait
continuer d'offrir parmi les tarifs les
plus bas au monde pour l'énergie avec de
nouveaux grands projets de barrage une
très bonne question Hydro-Québec
aujourd'hui les tarifs résidentiels les
plus attrayants au monde puis je pense
qu'on peut s'attendre à ce qui est au
Québec travaille à maintenir cet
écosystème-là dans son secteur
résidentiel ce qui va mettre la pression
sur le système électrique du Québec puis
éventuellement de la pression pour avoir
de grands barrages ça va vraiment être
la grande consommation industrielle or
il se trouve que nos tarifs industriels
sont également extrêmement
concurrentiels il y a de la place madame
Saint-Arnaud pour faire son intelligent
puis accompagner nos clients existants
puis attirer des gens qui vont venir
chez nous mais pas juste pour avoir une
électricité propre notre électricien est
propre et elle vaut cher alors l'idée
c'est pas de craquer un du mal le prix
industriel mais il faut vraiment
comprendre que si on construit des
ouvrages coûter 3 ou 4 fois ce que coûte
le bassin actuel de production on peut
pas attirer des gens ici puis leur faire
des contrats spéciaux ou des contrats
extraordinaires arabais alors qu'on sait
qu'on va construire et essentiellement
pour ces consommations là à coup plus
élevées donc l'idée c'est de ne pas être
le magasin à une pièce de l'électricité
propre dans le monde mais d'attirer les
gens qu'on veut des bonnes entreprises
qui ont des profils de consommation que
lesquels on va être confortable qui vont
créer de la richesse
au gouvernement de faire ses
arbitrages-là à nous notre chance de
faire évoluer le système électrique pour
y répondre très bien Madame brochez
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir un grand plaisir madame Satan pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]